hello there you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
Saturday's front pages as they arrive it
is time to see what's making the
headlines with broadcaster and former
conservative special advisor Anita
bateng and the daily mirrors political
editor John Stevens they'll be with us
from now right up until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
the front pages for you now learn work
skills or face benefits cut jobless told
reads the front of the times as it looks
at new plans to tackle unemployment
the mirror leads on comments made by
missing dog walker Nicola Bully's
partner the headline I'm certain Nicola
didn't fall in
the same story covers the front of the
Daily Mail as well
I'm a hundred percent convinced comments
from Nicola's partner is also the lead
on the telegraph
and the same again on the front of the
sun its headline someone local knows
something
the guardian reports that the treasuries
considering a plan to massively expand
free child care to one and two-year-olds
in England
an interview with the education
secretary leads the financial times over
the number of international students
studying in the UK
the I weekend continues its uk-wide
campaign on River conditions its
headline save our Rivers only six
percent will be healthy as UK's water
firms pump more raw sewage
tell us Harry are you coming to
coronation who's the front of the Daily
Express
and the Sun is falling to bits reads the
front of the Daily Star
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Anita boitang and John Stevens welcome
to you both let's start with
um the earthquakes in Turkey
um just looking at the front page of the
the ft
I sigh just because the the picture that
alongside the article is just
well it's just Indescribable grief isn't
it this is in andiaman and and families
having to
dig the bodies of loved ones from the
rubble before actually helping to dig
their graves
Anita
yes I mean the images that we have been
seeing for the past week have been
absolutely harrowing and what's really
coming through in some of the coverage
is that there's a lot of anger um in
Turkey like they do know that they are
on are susceptible to earthquakes and um
obviously some of the older buildings
haven't been made as kind of earthquake
proof but a lot of people in communities
have had to essentially provide their
own food and water and in this instance
you've got those devastating images of
people having to dig their own Grays the
Ft coverage also says there's a you know
50 person queue to get into a cemetery
um so there really is just an awful loss
of life that we're seeing it in Turkey
and just one other note for Syria where
um the UN has said that it thinks that
five million people are potentially
displaced and obviously we can't get
into Syria to see
um the extent of the damage but that is
a country that has been Riven
um and ravaged by so many crises that
it's hard to imagine the scale of what
they are going through too
yes and John as Anita mentioned there a
lot of the the grief turning to to anger
because of the
state of the the buildings and the fact
that they they collapse so easily and
not uh earthquake proof
um and some even today suggesting it
that it amounts to murder
yeah and you look at the death toll I
mean 22 000 people that just feels
completely unbelievable we're used to
Big Terror attacks where you know
the Paris parakeets that was 200 people
with used to kind of people die all
sorts of kind of things around the world
but 22 000 people is just such a vast
number and that picture on the front
page of the Ft as you say I mean you
just cannot describe the grief that is
so clearly on their faces but there is
one small glimmer of hope that is talked
about in that FTP so that is that they
are still finding some people alive the
British certs team has been helping
using dogs to try and find people who
are still alive under the rubble they
were tweeting early today how they'd
rescued a two-year-old girl that yeah it
is an absolutely Grim story but there
are these incredible Tales of people who
four days on from this terrible
earthquake are still being plucked alive
from the rubble yes and I suppose
although we were seeing it in our
coverage that the Emergency Services
um the the First Responders are exhaust
did they will continue to search for
people because you know there are these
uh glimmer of hopes when they're able to
to bring life from uh within the rubble
let us have a look at the mirror uh and
this is a story that's on many of the
front pages we'll look at the mirror
first of all the headline I'm certain
Nicola didn't fall in this is Nicola
Bully's partner who's given an interview
um and he says his personal view is that
she absolutely categorically did not
fall into the river Anita
yes um yeah yeah another Grim story for
Friday night um so we all know that what
happened which was she seems to have
disappeared walking her dog
um next to the river we're on the 27th
of January and um in the reports um that
we've seen in the mirror there or the
partner has said that he's sort of been
shocked when he saw sort of how shallow
the river was and is now saying that he
feels that they're
um you know the the this is not what
happened
um and the entire family they've been
holding vigils they clearly um
completely distraught and also baffled
um by what may have happened and they've
also got reports in the papers of
um hear her partner saying that um she
would not have left her dog
um and there's a and he's also sort of
raised the question of whether someone
someone might know something about
what's happened to her yeah that is the
headline for the sun John that someone
local knows something and he's saying
that he wants everywhere so thoroughly
not just the river every inch he wants
to to know that that it has been gone
through with a fine-tooth comb
yeah and this interview that he has
given I mean
really hard what he's going through
there is such a mystery that we're two
weeks on now and we don't seem really to
be any closer to working out what
exactly has happened to Nicola bully but
he's saying it's such a small village
you kind of she spent 12 years doing
this exact same dog route the same past
you see the same people every day I know
that as a dog walker you see the same
people in the park as you see one of the
days you see the same other dog walkers
and so he's saying that if there was
someone else around someone on The
Village would surely have recognized
them and thought you're not from around
here I've not seen your face before and
so he's just kind of pleading with the
people in the local area saying surely
someone somewhere must know something
but it's just clearly quite strange
what's happened and you can see why he
is questioning whether she did go in the
river or not you know things like her
phone being found on the bench most
people are glued to their phones the
whole time time that if you fell in the
river your phone would go with you the
fact that the dog Willow that was with
her that she had gone into the river it
was dry the dog suggests that you can
see why they're questioning this theory
about did she fall in the river or not
whether that is the case but yeah he
clearly wants the police to do
absolutely everything they can do he
used the phrase that he said we can have
no stone left unturned they just want
the police kind of widen the search make
sure that every Caravan every building
every outbuilding has been searched that
it just seems strange that two weeks on
there is kind of no real Clues as to
what happens and you can see why he's
just desperate for the police to kind of
turn up some indication of what exactly
has gone on absolutely is then the not
knowing that's so agonizing for for the
family let's turn to the times and this
story about benefit claimants um it'll
be required to spend a fortnight on an
intense program designed to get them
back into work or they could risk losing
Universal Credit payments Anita
um yeah so I'm former work and pension
pinch so I remember these policy
initiatives very well so the details of
this story are very interesting you've
got
um essentially there's something that
happens in in welfare where when you
have been out of a job for about three
months that's sort of the critical
period where it becomes more and more
difficult for you to get back into the
workforce so this initiative is um you
know that's been worked up and piloted
in the department for work and pensions
is essentially about that after that
three-month period can you have two
weeks of an intensive daily kind of
face-to-face program that will help you
kind of get back into work so there is a
suggestion that after
um you know you've been out of work for
three months or more if you kind of
repeatedly refuse to attend you could
lose your payments but it feels like
it's a lot more kind of carrot than
stick um so they're piloting this
according to the story in the times
um in four different areas and obviously
you know at the moment unemployment is
not particularly high but 1.2 million
people is a lot of people given how much
demand there is um for workers in the UK
right now so anything that the
department can do to get more people
into work to me is is to The Good the
palace here is a crawling in West Sussex
pontefract and West Yorkshire Patrick in
Glasgow and Coalville in leicestershire
um does it strike you as a good idea
John
I think it depends on the quality of
these courses if it is two weeks of
tailored how that it's not just a
one-size-fits-all thing it's not a book
sticking exercise where they are truly
looking at these people what skills they
have what jobs they'd be interested in
and helping them into jobs helping them
with their applications working out what
could you do to kind of freshen up your
skills if it is something like that then
that would be helpful I think for a lot
of people however if it is a low quality
thing that's quickly rolled out across
the country where it isn't kind of
specialized and customized to the people
who are needing the help then that seems
a bit of a pointless exercise and you
can see why you might end up with
problems down the road people saying
well I might actually be better off
spending two weeks going through job
search applications myself doing things
going to interviews rather being stuck
going to a course which may not be the
best thing for them to do we shall see
how the pilots progress John and Anita
for the moment thank you we're going to
take a break
coming up tell us Harry are you coming
to the coronation that's the front of
the Daily Express stay with us more on
that and Other Stories
[Music]
if you are watching The Press preview is
still with me broadcaster and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating and the daily mirrors political
editor John Stevens welcome back to both
of you let us take a look at the
Telegraph and the story that's been out
of the headlines for a wee while
partygate remember that
um well according to this report the
inquiry might be scuppered because
Witnesses are being told that they will
not be able to remain anonymous Anita
yes this is an interesting little return
of party gate um so the telegraph was
reporting but
um the investigation into whether Boris
Johnson misled knowingly misled um the
House of Commons into what he knew about
parties going on in Downing Street is
continuing and there is this indication
that the witnesses unless in exceptional
circumstances will not be able to remain
anonymous so there's some suggestion
here that Witnesses have therefore been
reluctant to come forward with WhatsApp
messages and other evidence and some
were saying well I no longer use my
government phone etc etc and so this
this investigation is supposed to move
to televised hearings in about March and
the telegraph things that there's going
to be a report in July so there's some
suggestion that this is going to be
somewhat stymied by this condition of
anonymity
um being removed except in exceptional
circumstances yes John the papers
reporting that that actually the
investigation is struggling to prove his
guilt could this all be thrown out do
you think
I think that you can see why people
might be put off giving kind of written
testimony if they're told that they'd be
named one of the quotes in the telegraph
talks about how it feels like turning on
the mafia kind of giving evidence
against Boris Johnson but you know it's
interesting that they're trying to get
hold of emails and WhatsApp messages and
that is something that you could easily
hand over kind of cache of messages of
WhatsApp groups what was being said by
different AIDS in number 10. you could
easily hand that over the investigation
and not be named by them and I think
that may be this sort of kind of hard
evidence that could be used to prove
that Boris Johnson was aware that what
he was saying wasn't true I think it's
all quite dependent on which WhatsApp
groups do you manage to get hold of and
do they involve groups that the Prime
Minister was a member of yeah yeah I'm
sure the the inquiry will will continue
we shall um see what this the
significance of uh people not being able
to maintain anonymity has on it let us
um just got time to have a look at the
Express and the question that they're
asking directly to Prince Harry is is he
coming for the coronation what do we
think Anita
who knows I mean clearly no one has been
told and there is this lingering um
concern about whether the kind of saga
of the deconductors of Sussex is going
to overshadow the coronation I I must
confess I can't quite see how it would
given it's you know
sorry to cut you but the express is
saying that that
um they both will soon be invited uh but
a quick decision is wanted on whether or
not they will attend but so it seems as
if they will be invited
yes so what I'm saying is that if they
did attend it's hard to imagine that
they would actually overshadow the um an
event that hasn't happened in several
decades in the UK so I think that it
feels like a bit of a story about
relatively nothing I honestly would be
quite surprised if they did come for the
coronation because it would it would
result in a lot of a media frenzy and a
lot of things
Anita thank you very much